[Music]
so time then for the press preview it's
our first look at what is on the front
pages of thursday's papers we're going
to check out the headlines tonight with
andrew pearce and kevin mcguire they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight very good evening gentlemen
we'll chat in a moment after we've had a
look at those front pages for you
starting with the telegraph leading on
fears that the price of a tank of petrol
could hit 100 pounds for the first time
tomorrow that's for a family car after
petrol prices jumped by two pence today
a hundred pounds to fill family car is
the headline for the mirror which calls
the rise in fuel prices a petrol crisis
the guardian also focuses on that hike
in petrol prices the biggest
daily price rise in 17 years along with
the forecast that the uk's economy is
set to slow to a standstill next year
at the ft leads on the warning from the
oecd that apart from russia the uk is on
track for the worst growth in the g20
well the times says the prime minister
will tomorrow announce plans which would
let lower paid workers use their housing
benefits to buy a house and end rules
that prevent the use of welfare payments
to get mortgages
three days of rail strikes at the end of
june will disrupt trains for almost a
week according to the eye with just one
in five passenger services expected to
run
the rail unions have no shame is the
metro's take after what it describes as
a non-apology from the boss of the rmt
union
meanwhile the daily mail has word that a
coalition of charities and a border
force trade union amounting a legal
challenge to halt plans to deport
migrants to rwanda
and the sun gives its front page to news
that the model kelly brooke is engaged
to be married
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you can see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch and listen to us and i'm joined
tonight by the consultant editor at the
daily mail andrew pearce and associate
editor at the daily mirror kevin mcguire
great to see you both last time we spoke
it was before the jubilee did you enjoy
the jubilee
was
kevin
jubilee did i miss it when was this
guy i must have yeah i think that
weekend if it was last weekend you're
talking about i went to see todd gunn
watched a bit of cricket uh you know it
was a quite nice uh sunny time yeah
well the rest of us the rest of us had a
good time um i can tell you that listen
let's start um i mean it's back to
reality isn't it after after all the uh
the fun last weekend front page of the
mirror
kevin says it all doesn't it a hundred
pounds to fill the family car uh despair
and fuel it furious fuel prices are
going to hit a record high i mean the
records seem to be broken every day
no absolutely another two uh 2p increase
uh talking about the biggest increase in
17 years the rac putting out that that
figure the the two pound uh liter on its
way which would be uh more than nine
pound if it was still shown in
gallons and it's it's probably the most
uh
obvious that uh
manifestation of the cost of living
crisis because you drive past any garage
any filling station and you will see the
prices uh there and it poses an
incredible problem for uh families
households anybody who uses a car also
people uh in the haulage business public
transport and it's a it's a huge
headache for uh
for us it's also a huge political
problem for the government because that
five payoff
fuel uh which the chancellor rishi sunak
announced has made next to no difference
what all at all and people are really
feeling the pinch yeah and andrew there
are also concerns that some retailers
aren't passing on that that 5p uh cut to
motorists and even those that are i mean
it's a tiny in comparison to to to the
increase
yeah it's it's it's simply not it simply
wasn't enough at the time and uh there
was evidence that most retailers didn't
pass it on there was a time you know
when the supermarkets used to have quite
um
lively price wars on the petrol four
course because it was a great way of
drawing cars in but they're not doing
that at the moment and and of course the
irony of this um is the government's
yield tax yield from fuel now would be
probably another all-time high because
although i imagine many families are put
trying to fill up the car less because
they simply can't afford it at these
prices the tax yield for the chancellor
is going to be pretty huge which i would
think then can give him more scope to do
more to help families and perhaps sooner
than the budget which is not due till
november um kevin it it it sort of leads
into uh another miserable front page as
well all about uk uh growth it's set to
be the worst in the g20 according to the
oecd forecast today apart from russia uh
that is
yeah it's a very own an unenviable
record the uh the ft are leading on that
uh and of course growth this year three
point six percent uh is uh you know is
nothing to shout about but it's not bad
but zero growth next year why why is the
british economy doing so badly and so
much worse and france and spain and
italy the us and japan
all except sanctioned russia which is
being penalized economically for
invading
ukraine um all governments all chances
all prime ministers politicians like to
boast about how the economy is doing
well boris johnson has
done it frequently as has the uh
chancellor richie
they won't be able to do it when when
britain has just been absolutely
clobbered now inflation will fall but it
will mean another very very um poor time
and that will again squeeze living
standards and uh and hit the public
finances but why is it so bad
ft asia doesn't explain it but it is
pretty pretty awful and it's a it's a
record you do not want to boast about it
it's a record you want to be ashamed of
yeah well we put that question um to the
oecd today and they said it it's down to
uh fiscal tightening and that's one of
the reasons but also they cited brexit
well i think actually the big factor
here is the fact we're the only
government in europe that's putting up
taxes i can't understand why we're doing
it we're putting up national insurance
uh crazy shouldn't have happened i know
a lot of people were taken out of
national insurance people earning up to
12 000 pounds but far too many people
being dragged into it and also a lot
more people are going to be being
dragged into the 40 tax rate uh people
who shouldn't be police officers that
sort of thing and we now know don't we
that the tax burden is the highest in
this country for 70 to 75 years it's
nuts we've got to cut taxes to stimulate
demand stimulate the economy uh and
boris johnson wants to reset his
premiership after that bruising
confidence vote last week which by the
way kierstama oddly didn't mention at
one of his worst ever performances the
primes as questions today but he wants
to reset his premiership by getting
police getting on the front foot policy
wise but he's got to get on the front
foot by sorting out the cost of living
crisis first
yeah it's the same story on the front
page of the guardian fuel cost surge and
dire economic forecast shutter pm's
hopes uh of that reset what do you think
we're going to hear tomorrow kevin
well
from the government we'll hear a lot of
bluster won't we we won't we won't hear
from boris johnson uh an admission that
he he lied about brexit and it's been a
disaster for the economy that's chris
trade
uh had a huge uh financial impact create
bureaucracy there's no benefits that you
can see he won't do that he's just going
to he's going to do his old uh
boosterism and buster that's what that's
what he does but he's divorced from
reality
so you're not going to get the truth or
any objective analysis from boris
johnson he's just going to dig in and
it'll be more of the same more of the
same that's a disaster that's really
that's what he's going to do with
lancashire we know he's going to speak
but we're asked not to reveal exactly
where it is always said for security
reasons what they really don't want our
protesters turning up
to dog but brexit well if that's
crushing growth he was the architect of
that uh referendum victory very narrow
victory just divided the country took a
lot of uh
energy out of other issues uh spread a
or a poison but he won't admit the truth
because he one he never does and two
brexit got him the job in number 10 but
everyone else paying the price okay
andrew give me a very quick response to
that and then i'm going to ask you
briefly about the front of the metro
well the the fact is when you change the
financial arrangement which you've been
in for about 46 years it's it's
complicated it takes time and i think
we'll see the benefits of brexit when we
emerge from the post
pandemic economy uh it's it's i mean
we've been battered by the pandemic
we've also got higher inflation than
some of our eu rivals so i'm not and
it's anything like as gloomy about
brexit as kevin mcguire who can't he's
never come to terms with the result in
the first place nor of any of his ramona
mates okay yeah i i don't remember when
you were advocating uh brexit saying it
would be terrible it would crush the
economy well i didn't know there was
going to be an epidemic
i'd love to carry this on we are out of
time i'm just going to show the front
page of the metro uh it's about the uh
forthcoming plans for uh industrial
action on the railways no shame is their
headline we'll talk about that after 11
o'clock hello again welcome back to the
press preview andrew and kevin's still
with us uh front page of the daily mail
andrew um uh rwanda and as uh i think
many predicted uh it looks as if there
could be a legal challenge to that to
those first deportations
of course there was always going to be
it's the kevin's mates the human rights
lawyers um waving their legal papers
lots of legal aid no doubt involved uh
and it was always there's this this
policy
many many deportations not just to to
rwanda many deportations of criminals uh
back to various countries that are
blocked on the runway by human rights
lawyers uh this this policy is always
always going to inflame the human rights
lobby uh and it's frankly a battle that
i suspect pretty patella home
secretary's rather looking forward to
because i think she'll find the public
is on her side
kevin
look i believe in the rule of law that
the law should be followed and something
like seven in 10 asylum claims in the uk
are found to be legitimate when people
cross the
channel andrew may not like it but they
are legitimate so if you're going to put
people uh unlawfully on a plane they're
entitled to appeal against it and the
policy of rwanda is really to get paid
from pages on the daily mail and so on
it's what jesse norman the former
conservative minister and uh the tory mp
uh very close to boris johnson in the
past it's an ugly policy
it's just meant to inflame people that's
what it's about it's also going to be
hugely expensive you can you can fall
for it
and want it want to be part of that ugly
policy or you could think we in britain
should be a civilized country and follow
the law you can you know you can do one
night and do the other i want to follow
the law
okay uh home office insiders telling the
mail that the chances of the first
flight taking off as planned are now
slim uh very quickly andrew quick look
at this story we've touched on it
already um announcement tomorrow the
time seems to have a bit more detail
when it comes to housing
yeah so we know that um boris johnson is
going to
massively extend right to buy the great
thatcher policy of the 1980s on council
houses to housing association properties
two and a half million people in those
properties want more people to be able
to buy them but interestingly too big a
big change here a big shift it's
suggesting for the first time he's going
to say that people on benefits they can
weaponize their housing benefits to
actually try to get mortgages about 30
billion pounds is spent on housing
benefit every year the prime minister's
point is most of that goes to subsidize
rented accommodation why not to see if
there's a way in which they can use that
money to buy their own property which
would give people on much lower incomes
a chance to get a foot on the housing
ladder if they can persuade the building
sites and banks to go along with it i
think it sounds a really good idea okay
we'll talk more about that uh in a few
minutes time front page of the times as
well just give me 10 seconds on this
kevin love drugs are on the horizon
according to oxford university
yeah according to uh give your partner a
love drug and you won't really bother if
they uh leave the toilet seat up well
i'll believe it when it happens
i thought i thought love drugs have been
around since the 60s my mistake we'll
talk more about that as well
thank you very much indeed